c'est donc l'heure de vérité pour fouler
ponsard son procès débute aujourd'hui
ils devraient durer cinq jours après la
lecture des faits dans la présidente de
cette cour d'assises à la grande
surprise de sousse flippant sahara se
lève et le dis je demande pardon à la
famille et je reconnais ma culpabilité
dans ce dossier un moment très important
pour la famille de français pierre minne
qui attendait depuis quatre ans ce
procès à cette cour d'assises de fort de
france
j'attends un jugement un je veux que
l'affairé soit jugée au qu'on puisse
aussi tourné j'allais dire cette page
judiciaire qui dure depuis longtemps et
qui est très difficile à vivre à
supporter le sujet revient tout le temps
on en parle sans arrêt entre nous dans
la famille je veux dire que
nous espérons que le jugement une fois
que le jugement soit rendu
on pourra tourner ne fait pas judiciaire
en tout cas vous entendez quand même la
vérité de fripons ça je l'espère
l'attendre c'est moins sûr
une première victoire pour les avocats
de la défense au départ fait responsa
était placé dans le box vitré m
bellemans maîtres philippe
edmond-mariette on dort fils et demande
à la présidente de la cour d'assises de
fort de france
malgré l'opposition de l'avocat général
faux répond sarah est sorti du boxeur
vitré et les maintenant assis à côté de
ses avocats
premier à la barre le directeur non kate
il retrace toutes les étapes tout
notamment les nombreuses investigations
qui ont pu conduire à la piste de felipe
tard dans l'après midi
d'autres témoins défileront à la barre
notamment plusieurs femmes qui déclarent
avoir été agressée par philippe pons art